welcome to a game spot plays I'm Jake
and I'm here with Alex how you doing
Alex hey pretty good we are about to
jump into how to full boyfriend now if
you don't know this is the pigeon dating
simulator yeah it's actually published
by devolver in the United States
originally though it came out in 2011 in
Japan it was localized in English came
out in 2012 then devolver picked it up
and remade it for pc in 2014 now just
yesterday it came out on the ps4 and PS
Vita is ten bucks and it's crossed by
and it's pretty amazing that amazing is
one word for it I guess yeah so we're
going to jump in right here i've
actually played about 10 minutes of it
so far so we're gonna jump in like 10
minutes in and just right off the bat
what is tanabata you know what I don't
know that's a good question i think it's
some sort of holiday maybe it's there's
a you know big this is a big back
straight of this game that i'm not
really sure about quite yet i don't know
if anyone is it's pretty obtuse but it's
also hilarious so basically the gist of
it is is that it's a visual novel and
you go to school with pigeons and you're
a human right you're human girl yeah and
some girl my yeah you pigeons are your
thing you just want to get in there get
all dirty with pigeons and yes you do
and my my humans name is berto Williams
I don't know why if ya were you
imagining like Berto from like Super
Mario absolutely ok so uh right away we
were given a choice what should we what
should we wish for I'm just like this
tree where you put wishes on I think we
should wish to conquer the world by
force because obviously like conquest of
the world is a great goal yeah I mean as
long as you've got pigeons by your side
yeah and so I wish to crush all
opposition that rises before me and rule
the world with an iron exactly that's an
admirable goal and I think we'll go with
that so this is the teacher of the class
who is narcoleptic and falls asleep all
the time and can you date it I think you
can um hit him her him him him so he
just offered to walk me home because I'm
out late
so I'm gonna I think well I think you
can't yes please yes should we have the
teacher waka so I think we're shy the
teacher walkers yeah alright so the
narcoleptic teacher is going to watch us
walk us home hopefully he'll get us home
safely yeah so we demonstrated some
extreme sleeping because of course he
falls asleep all the time not the best
teacher I'm living in a cave so your
house is very rustic yeah so you get
like new places or you just live in any
case you're just looking yeah girl in a
good and the pigeons have real house is
that bad right the pigeons have houses
they have scooters they have all sorts
yeah Baird and we live in a cave doing
the scooty we don't have a scooter yet I
hope hopefully you can bye see you later
the hollow sounding fell apparently our
narcoleptic teacher has a little bit of
existential angst going on his farewell
to us was just was hollow sounding
apparently so this this is kind of like
the the framework of each you know quote
unquote day that you have at school so
you have you're given a choice of three
different classes to go to i'm gonna
guess they up here vitality yet wisdom
in charisma yep i've been those i don't
think those mean anything vitality is
820 the rest is kennel elegant eyetality
of help so have you lost health in this
game now so now so i've i've generally
only go to math class because you know
you got to get your mat your brain
stronger and more attuned to calculus
and all this stuff so we're gonna go to
that class musics not gonna be anyone I
kneelers Jenn McKee work sorry I'm
alright so yeah the narcoleptic teacher
thinks calculus is used useless it's
that's why he's asleep oh yeah yeah
exactly it means a teacher not doing
anything good at his life no you know he
really hasn't gotten very far in life
he's just keeps falling falling asleep
and
yeah so questions carry diseases so what
I want to know you know actually I don't
want to know right so it's it depends on
what your definition of disease is is
you know talking like STDs I don't know
yet that's something that will happen
you go later okay so we might find out
yeah i mean we're at a swimming class
and out with pigeons and apparently
Berto Williams wait you into math class
and you go to you we went to math class
my wisdom increased by five points and
now we're a swimming class I didn't have
a choice and I met are they just sing in
a sewing class and apparently the tight
clean feathers are making Berto Williams
a little excited so that is good so
these two doves are brothers the one on
the left is like more I guess like a
full breed of and he's obnoxious he's
not yet he is Sakuya and security is
obnoxious the he's an aristocrat very
pretentious as you can see he yeah he's
very uptight very full of himself okay
what oh you always have to have one of
those right but brutal they would be
pigeons or people exactly and I think
Berto Williams is kinda into Sakuya so
I'm obviously gonna pick Sakuya in this
race okay yeah oh you getting the
brothers initially obviously Russians
would happen play them off each other
yeah um I'm gonna judge their noble
combat with all possible fairness of
course because I'm fair I think that
security over will win because that
aristocracy gives a leg up in the
swimming competition okay ya know so so
they're racing yea verily the road with
perfect this I her brothers I mean yeah
so apparently this world is some sort of
weird like I feel like there might have
been a nuclear war something that what
pigeons being mutated with hyper
intelligent you know the ability to be
super intelligent aim to swim apparently
can to run track for that matter since I
post-apocalyptic that's my that's my
inner gay yeah so sadly secured and when
you yo edge amount but so cute is not
very happy with that so before we came
in here you were you were playing around
a little bit and you actually died yeah
so hopefully we'll get to that but I I
still don't know what happened so
hopefully we'll be able to figure that
out we're playing through that same
sequence right now um so the pigs are as
big as the human or is there are we
taller I mean is it like I what's the
scale did its its its normal scale just
no one thinks it's weird that there's
just a human walking around in a pigeon
world okay but the pigeons are still
little yeah ah so there's this here's
the video game he's a sparrow oh this is
actually she she's a sparrow she has a
scooter see pigeon scooter what happens
if he a triangle that's a that's fast
forward you can ask what others have you
played it I feel see I don't get that
what kind of pressure this train
Federation it that little weird
maybe I don't know it's yeah this game
is also the music is incredible in this
game at one point I heard the the dance
of the Sugar Plum fairies the other song
um fine Democrat but that was flying to
sonny jim it's got it's got a nice
guitar yeah I liked Rick yeah so then we
have the metal backing to the
introduction of the sparrow who is
offering me a ride home because she
likes to cut of my gym all right all
right I now do would you like someone's
gym I mean it's hard to say I mean if
you run this iteration maybe I mean I
that wouldn't be the first thing that
came to mind if I was talking to a
pigeon yeah how long is this supposed to
be I think total hours it hasn't quite
the branching storyline there's so you
could do multiple play to ya if you so
choose you could not die 30 minutes in I
yeah so it's probably the best bet
Bertos in here on the Nutcracker
narcoleptic teachers of sleep again this
same old same old yeah so we're trying
to figure out the mystery of this ID
card she found the hall no one really
knows where it came from do you think
it's a lot of the birds pocket
potentially but the plot thickens
because it's the first day of school no
one's in the school yet this student has
been absence in the middle of june and
the IED card was a lying there all
summer oh it was a little more to this
story in a skating pigeons it was clean
there's there's a little bit about you
know I feel like a murder mystery vibe
going on here so it's a lot deeper than
just dating pigeons although dating
pictures is of course the highlight of
it hmm I love watching the stars in that
I can feel the excitement bubbling from
light-years away yodelayheehoo huh
ninjas
okay ah so yeah so ventures and so you
died I don't know the games done I did
you read the lot the the slide before I
think the the same pigeon tens or
whatever the that institution sent
decided that I was not worth the time
they spend on having this sort of
experiment of having a human occasion
school and okay I think that's what an
experiment yeah thank you a nice bench
and you got executed that's one way to
handle your failed experiments yeah but
anyway that was pigeon simulator if this
is something you're interested in by all
means go check it out if you're into
pigeons if you're into dating sims and
if you're into I don't know visual
novels be sure to check this out it's on
PlayStation 4 pc and playstation vita
it's ten bucks stay tuned gamespot for
more games flop plays and all sorts of
other fun stuff see ya
you